Et donc toutes les sources des joies que l'apôtre Paul a pu goûter dans sa vie, intellectuelle, en tant que professionnel, car tous de son métier reconnaissaient quelle position il avait.
Et donc c'était quelqu'un de très réussi dans la vie, si on peut dire comme ça.
Mais lorsqu'il a connu véritablement l'évangile du Seigneur Jésus-Christ, lorsqu'il a perçu que tout son château de sable, cette connaissance, ne l'amenait pas à la bonne conclusion, à la bonne source de réjouissance,
il a finalement arrêté de trouver de la joie dans les circonstances directement, mais il a dit que l'excellence de la connaissance du Seigneur Jésus-Christ a fait qu'il considère toutes les autres sources de joie qu'il avait comme de la bouée.
Et donc à partir de là, on voit clairement que les fondements suprêmes de sa joie étaient laissés en Jésus-Christ car il est la source de joie suprême.
Mais notamment le Seigneur Jésus-Christ, non seulement par la source inépuisable des joies qu'il est dans la contemplation de ses vertus, dans la réjouissance de son amour,
mais aussi à cause du fait que le Seigneur Jésus-Christ a fait pour Paul ce qu'il a fait pour nous.
Il a pourvu les seuls moyens de réconciliation avec Dieu de la manière la plus sublime et extraordinaire possible.
C'est-à-dire que toutes les vertus du Christ sont particulièrement et surtout constatées par l'œuvre qu'il a fait à notre faveur.
Et c'est Jésus-Christ qui a vécu la vie parfaite à notre place, qui a mort à la croix pour nous,
qui nous a délivrés ainsi de la coupabilité, de la condamnation à l'enfer,
qui nous a réconciliés avec la source suprême de notre bonheur car Dieu nous a créés pour lui,
et qui assure pour nous, dans les mondes à venir pour toujours, dans un monde sans guerre, sans policier, sans hôpital,
la restauration pleine de notre corps en réjouissant avec Christ.
Voilà pourquoi il va finir les chapitres 3 au verset 20 et 20 en disant,
« Mais notre cité à nous est dans les cieux, d'où nous attendons aussi comme serveurs le Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
qui transformera les corps de notre humiliation en les rendant semblables au corps de sa gloire
par les pouvoirs qu'il a d'assujettir toutes les choses. »
Donc il a compris, comme tous les chrétiens doivent comprendre,
qu'il est fondément ultime de notre joie, elle est Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
et qui même si la réjouissance pleine et suprême de cette joie se donnera dans un monde parfait
avec une contemplation directe de la beauté du Christ dans toute sa gloire,
nous pouvons déjà anticiper certains de cette joie
en comprenant davantage et en connaissant davantage de manière théorique,
mais surtout expérimentale, le Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Par la grâce qu'il peut nous accorder pendant cette vie difficile,
lorsqu'il, pendant notre pèlerinage, il pourvoit des bonnes choses,
mais aussi, et de manière assez particulière,
par les souffrances que nous pouvons traverser en conformité aux souffrances qu'il lui-même a souffert.
Ce qui va rendre notre intimité avec lui encore plus ressentie,
car par la tribulation on s'approche davantage du Christ,
et ça nous fera comprendre davantage tout ce qu'il a souffert pour nous,
qui sera toujours infiniment plus que ce que nous pouvons souffrir dans cette vie.
Et donc, Paul, il peut dire
qu'il est déterminé à embrasser même les souffrances
pour devenir conforme à Christ dans sa mort,
pour parvenir, si je puis, à la résurrection des morts,
je cours vers les buts de remporter les prix,
la vocation céleste et de juin Jésus-Christ.
Donc, les grands prix du chrétien, c'est les plus tôt que possible,
connaître les plus de Christ qui est possible,
de la manière la plus expérimentale qui est possible,
que ce soit par l'abondance ou par la disette.
Ok ?
Donc, l'apôtre Paul nous montre Christ,
elle est fondémentine de la joie chrétienne,
et quand il arrive au chapitre 4,
il va présenter plusieurs applications
de comment les chrétiens peuvent réjouir de cette joie.
Et nous sommes en train de considérer
ces formes variées de trouver notre joie
dans notre pèlerinage,
dans ce qui reste de notre temps, dans ce monde,
pour commencer à nous habituer avec notre Seigneur,
notre joie,
commencer à nous habituer avec la réalité céleste.
Et de manière très résumée,
c'est en Christ qui nous trouvons cette joie,
et c'est dans la promotion du Christ
qui nous trouvons cette joie.
Et nous avons,
nous avons considéré jusqu'ici,
trois sources de joie
pendant notre pèlerinage.
Chapitre 4, verset 1 à 5,
nous parle de la joie,
de la fraternité,
d'une église locale
où nous avons des relations véritables,
des relations profondes,
des relations remplies d'affection.
L'apôtre Paul avait une affection particulière
pour les Philippiens.
C'était la même chose
de la part des Philippiens
envers l'apôtre Paul.
Et c'est en elle
que l'apôtre Paul avait
envers la fermeté de cette église
et une relation qui a été bâtie
sur la base de services
et de l'unité.
Et donc là, nous voyons de manière très claire
l'importance d'avoir une famille.
Des fois, nous voyons la répétition
dans les versets 1 à 5
de ces aspects très affectueux
de l'apôtre Paul
envers les Philippiens.
Ensuite,
la deuxième chose qu'on a considérée
comme source des joies
au chapitre 4,
c'est notamment la prière communautaire.
Lorsque dans la communauté,
nous nous rassemblons pour prier,
pour faire connaître à Dieu
non seulement nos besoins,
mais nos désirs même légitimes.
Et nous goûtons par là
la joie
d'expérimenter la paix des dieux
qui surpasse toute intelligence.
et donc,
par les prières communautaires,
par l'unité de l'Église dans la prière,
l'Église, elle pouvait réjouir,
non simplement et directement
des réponses des prières
pour lesquelles ils ont prié,
mais rien que par la pratique constante
de la prière communautaire,
avoir cette paix
qui rend qu'on soit
véritablement joyeux
indépendamment des réponses
que Dieu puisse donner.
C'est la paix d'avoir déposé
dans les mains du Père
toutes nos préoccupations
pour écraser
cet ennemi
irrationnel
de la foi chrétienne
qui est l'anquiétude
ou l'anxiété.
Complètement irrationnel.
Car Dieu est un Père
pour ses enfants.
Il est tout-puissant
et il a du plaisir
à entendre tous nos désirs.
Une fois qu'on a déposé
dans les mains du Seigneur,
des dieux,
les pères,
toutes nos préoccupations,
il n'y a plus aucune raison
pour être dans l'anquiétude.
Et donc, par la prière,
la paix des dieux,
le troisième aspect
du verset 8 et 9,
la progression en sainteté,
la résolution des progressés
en sainteté,
la détermination
à ne pas marcher
par aucune voie
qui naît soit à la sainteté,
nous trouvons la joie
du dieu de la paix.
Donc,
le dieu de la paix
sera avec vous.
Donc,
vous voyez
l'équilibre
ou la symétrie glorieuse
entre d'un côté
par la prière,
j'égoutte la paix des dieux,
par ces moments d'intimité
avec mon dieu,
mon Père,
envers qui j'élance
toutes mes préoccupations
et en réponse
par la résolution.
Donc,
je suis préoccupé parfois
car il me semble
que je ne peux plus avancer
dans la vie
devant toutes ces difficultés
si je ne peux
compromettre ma foi.
C'est impossible.
Les situations
étaient tellement difficiles
que j'ai dû faire ceci
ou j'ai dû faire cela.
Par contre,
ici,
Paul est en train de montrer
qu'il y a un chrétien
résolu à dire
voici mon Père,
toutes mes préoccupations
car je veux rester fidèle
et je suis déterminé
à ne pas sortir
du schéma de la fidélité.
Et donc,
en priant,
on se repose
dans la paix des dieux
et en réponse
à cette prière,
Dieu démontre
sa présence
au milieu de nous.
Et même si
les peuples des dieux
se trouvent devant
un Goliath
paralysé,
il apparaîtra
un homme des dieux
qui a beaucoup plus
d'intimité
avec la présence des dieux
qu'avec la taille
du géant,
il est plus intime
de la taille des dieux
qu'il est de la taille
d'un géant,
il va faire face
à un Goliath
comme s'il n'était rien.
Donc,
l'intégrité passe
par l'intimité
avec Dieu
dans la prière
et la certitude
de la présence des dieux
avec nous
devant toutes circonstances
car même si la mer rouge
est fermée,
Dieu peut l'ouvrir.
Il n'y a pas de chèmement,
il n'y a pas de sortie,
Dieu va l'ouvrir
car il aime bien
qu'on marche
dans l'échelon
de la doiture
et de la sainteté.
Les purs des cœurs
verront Dieu
et voilà Paul,
il est en train
de dire cela.
Je suis emprisonné
mais tout est en train
de bien se passer.
L'évangile avance,
Dieu est avec moi.
Vous comprenez ?
Donc,
par la résolution
envers la sainteté,
les dieux de la paix.
Et depuis la semaine dernière,
on a commencé
à considérer
un quatrième aspect
de cette joie.
Nous allons continuer
aujourd'hui
et c'est ce qu'on trouve
entre les versets 10
à 19.
On a fait les versets
10 à 13
où on a considéré
cette quatrième vérité,
c'est que
dans les seigneurs,
pendant notre pèlerinage,
nous,
les chrétiens,
pouvons trouver la joie
de manifester
nos soins affectueux
envers un ministre
de l'Évangile.
Et bien sûr,
par là,
participer
à l'avancement
de l'Église,
mais c'est clair
ici dans ces passages
que nous sommes exposés
à une relation
très intime,
très soigneuse
entre les Philippiens
et l'apôtre Paul.
Et donc,
il dit,
j'ai éprouvé
une grande joie
dans les seigneurs
de ce qui vous avez pu
enfin renouveler
l'expression
de vos sentiments
pour moi.
Et donc,
ce qu'on a considéré
déjà,
c'était
plusieurs aspects
de cette joie
qu'on trouve
lorsqu'on est en train
de manifester
nos soins affectueux
envers un ministre
de l'Évangile.
Il y a d'abord
la joie
de recevoir
ces soins affectueux.
Donc,
l'apôtre Paul,
au verset 10,
il va dire,
moi,
j'ai éprouvé
une grande joie
dans les seigneurs.
Donc,
c'est intéressant,
Paul ici,
il est en train de dire
qu'il a éprouvé
une joie
vraiment maximisée,
une grande joie.
Et donc,
nous voyons
de manière très claire
que les soins
que nous investissons,
les soins généreux
que nous exprimons
envers un homme
des dieux,
il produit
la joie.
Donc,
Paul,
il est en train
d'expérimenter
cette joie.
C'est intéressant
car les langages,
c'est clair pour nous tous,
nous ne sommes pas
devant
la
la démonstration
explicite
de ce que Paul
a reçu
en termes matérielles.
Nous ne sommes pas
ici devant
et ça,
c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
dans l'écriture.
Nous voyons
que la vie nous présente
plusieurs principes
pour honorer
les pasteurs
mais elle ne donne
jamais les chiffres.
Et donc,
ici,
c'est intéressant
car l'une des intentions
des dieux,
c'est de nous éloigner
du langage monétaire,
du langage
de l'argent.
Quelle est la description
des passages ?
C'est,
vous avez pu
enfin renouveler
l'expression
de vos sentiments
envers moi.
Donc,
c'est une manifestation
d'amour
que cette église
est en train de faire
envers l'apôtre Paul.
Et donc,
la joie de l'apôtre Paul
par la réception
de ses biens
n'était pas la joie
de l'apôtre Paul
par son attachement
à ces choses.
C'était la joie
de l'apôtre Paul
car il était en train
de contempler
par ses soins
l'expression
proportionnelle
de l'amour
de cette église
à l'apôtre Paul.
Et donc,
il dit
qu'il a reçu
l'expression
de leurs sentiments
et donc,
c'était les sentiments
d'une église légitime
les philippiens
envers l'apôtre Paul.
Mais c'est intéressant
aussi de remarquer
que quand il dit
qu'il a éprouvé
une grande joie
dans les seigneurs,
c'est que cette église
par cette expression
d'amour
était en train
d'être un instrument
de Dieu.
Elle était en train
d'être les bras
du Seigneur Jésus
pour manifester
les sentiments
du Seigneur Jésus
pour son ministre.
Vous comprenez
quel est le privilège
de participer à ces dons ?
C'est le privilège
de savoir
que nous pouvons
avoir et goûter
la même joie
du Seigneur,
le même amour
du Seigneur
qu'il a
pour ses ministres fidèles
qui se sont consacrés
au ministère
et qui parfois
traversent des moments
très difficiles
à cause
de leur service.
Et donc là,
le premier aspect,
c'est la joie
de recevoir
un amour soigneux
de la part de l'Église.
C'est la joie
qu'il a pour très
plus expérimenté.
Mais Paul,
ici,
il est en train
de manifester aussi
qu'il reconnaissait
la joie
des Philippiens
dans les dons.
Comme le Seigneur Jésus
dit,
il y a plus
des joies,
les plus bienheureux,
c'est celui
qui donne
que celui
qui reçoit.
Et donc ici,
c'est intéressant,
Paul,
il n'est pas en train
de dire
qu'il a éprouvé
une grande joie
dans le Seigneur
de ce qu'il a reçu,
mais attention,
de ce qu'il vous avait
pu,
enfant.
Donc,
il y avait quelque chose
que les Philippiens
voulaient réaliser
pour trouver
leur propre joie.
Car il dit,
vous y pensez bien,
mais l'occasion
vous manquait.
Donc,
imaginez-vous
la frustration
lorsque nous aimons
quelqu'un,
nous voyons
que cette personne
est dans la détresse,
nous voulons honorer
cette personne
car on est devant
la dignité
de leur service,
mais les circonstances
ne nous permettent pas.
Et Paul savait
que cette Église
était en train
d'éprouver des tristesses
car elle savait,
elle aimait
l'apôtre Paul
et savait
que lui,
il était en train
dégoûté de la tristesse.
Et donc,
Paul,
il est dans la joie,
dans les seigneurs,
pas à cause
des choses
qu'il a reçues,
mais à cause
du fait
que cette Église
elle a pu finalement
donner généreusement
et satisfaire
la joie
et la détermination
et les désirs
qu'ils avaient
de bénir l'apôtre Paul.
Donc,
la joie des Philippiens
de pouvoir plaire
et réconforter
un homme des dieux.
Et c'est intéressant
car ils étaient
et nous goûtons
cette joie
non seulement
lorsqu'on fait un don,
à n'importe quel missionnaire
fidèle
ou quel homme
des dieux fidèles,
mais c'est une joie
particulièrement liée
à une relation personnelle
très intime.
Donc,
c'est vos sentiments,
pas tout simplement
envers les ministères
ou envers les ministres,
c'est qu'il y a déjà
digne et bon,
mais c'était
vos sentiments
pour moi.
Donc,
c'était intéressant
de voir
comment cette relation
de l'apôtre Paul
était consciente
que c'était une église
qui l'aimait véritablement
et qui a pu finalement
manifester cet amour.
OK ?
Le troisième aspect
qu'on a vu
ensemble
la semaine dernière,
c'était la joie
du contentement chrétien.
Et ça,
c'est vraiment,
on a pris du temps
car c'est vraiment
l'une des leçons
les plus glorieuses
de toutes les Écritures
vis-à-vis
au rapport des croyants
vers l'argent,
vers les biens temporels,
etc.
C'est pour apprendre
que
le Seigneur Jésus,
même s'il est
le propriétaire
de l'or
et de l'argent,
s'il est le propriétaire
du monde
tout entier,
même s'il a fait
de nous
ses héritiers
et nous allons
tout hériter
glorieusement
quand on arrivera
à la gloire,
mais le Seigneur Jésus
dans sa sagesse,
Dieu le perd
n'a pas décidé
pour nous
de tout simplement
déverser sur nos vies
toutes ces choses déjà.
Il y a une école
dans la sagesse
des dieux
qui va faire
que son peuple
traverse
l'école
du contentement
qui est une école
qui fait usage
à tout temps
de toutes circonstances.
Et donc
les variations
des conditions
des vies
qu'on va traverser
sont les moyens
qui Dieu va utiliser
pour nous apprendre
à trouver
exclusivement
notre contentement
en lui.
OK ?
Et donc c'est intéressant
car particulièrement,
restez avec moi,
à travers les ministres
fidèles,
en général,
c'est une chose
qui Dieu traite
très tôt,
très vite
dans la vie
des ministres
des dieux.
Il permet
que ces hommes
traversent
l'école
de la privation
pour qu'ils puissent
constater,
attester
que Christ
est leur souverain
bien
et que même
si tous les manquent,
rien ne les manque.
Et il permet
aussi dans sa grâce
que certaines saisons
dans la vie
d'un ministre
soient marquées
par l'honneur,
par la générosité,
par l'abondance.
Car en ayant
les préparés
à être fidèles
dans les peu,
ils ne perdent pas
leur cœur
lorsqu'ils ont beaucoup.
Et c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
dans la Bible,
comme l'apôtre Paul
est en train de dire ici,
ce n'est pas
en vue,
verset 11,
de mes besoins
que j'ai dit cela,
car j'ai appris
à être content
de l'état
où je me trouve.
J'essaie de vivre
dans l'humiliation,
j'essaie de vivre
dans l'abondance.
Donc là,
il a maîtrisé
parce qu'il dit
j'essaie,
c'est car,
regarde ce qu'il dit,
j'essaie aujourd'hui
de vivre dans l'humiliation
dans l'abondance,
car en tout
et partout
j'ai appris.
Donc,
en tout
et partout.
Donc,
Dieu a permis
que l'apôtre Paul
traverse
et l'efforce
à embrasser
certaines circonstances
difficiles
dans sa vie
pour que Dieu
puisse l'apprendre
quelque chose.
Et le bien suprême
de la vie
de tous les chrétiens,
c'est les contentements
en Jésus-Christ.
seul.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Oui.
Mais ce qui est intéressant
à remarquer,
c'est que si les contentements
en Jésus-Christ
seuls
sont notre bien
les plus précieux,
l'Église,
attention,
elle peut
se réjouir
dans la détermination
à participer
des soins
d'un ministre,
car dans les cas
des Philippiens,
ils étaient empêchés
dans certaines reprises,
car même s'ils avaient
envie de couvrir
cet homme
des ressources généreuses
pour qui rien ne les manquent
lorsqu'il sert,
elle a été empêchée.
Mais elle a continué
d'accompagner,
d'entendre parler.
Et même si elle était
complètement empêchée
d'aider,
l'apôtre Paul
persévérait,
même par la privation,
à faire l'évangile avancer.
Les seigneurs
ne manquaient pas.
De manière extraordinaire,
de manière surnaturelle,
les seigneurs
continuaient
de pourvoir
à ce dont Paul
avait besoin
pour faire
son royaume avancer.
Voilà pourquoi
l'apôtre Paul dit
ce que vous avez
vu en moi,
appris de moi
et entendu de moi.
Car même si
vous étiez frustré
de ne pas
venir m'aider,
l'Écrit
ne m'a jamais manqué.
Donc lorsqu'une église
est déterminée,
résolue
à suivre
un ministère fidèle,
à garder
leurs yeux
attentifs
à tous les parcours
dès les commencements
jusqu'à la fin,
elle n'arrive pas
à des conclusions
précipitées
si elle contemple
tout simplement
les moindes souffrances
et qu'elle puisse se dire
peut-être que Dieu
n'est pas en train
d'honorer cette personne
ou lorsqu'ils sont
dans une période
d'abondance,
c'est quelqu'un
qui aime l'argent.
Et donc c'est
très important
de contempler
tout l'historique.
Et qu'est-ce que
l'église va apprendre ?
Que Dieu ne manque
jamais
à ses serviteurs fidèles
et à la mesure
où nous tous,
membres d'une église
qui avons pour repère
un ministre fidèle,
nous lançons
progressivement
à la promotion
de l'évangile
en prenant des risques,
en renonçant
parfois
des promotions,
en posant
nos journées
pour nous consacrer
au service,
nous allons constater
que tout comme
le Seigneur
a pourvu pour Paul
et le pouvoir
a pour nous tous.
Et donc c'est
une école
de contentement
qui nous apprenons
par nos propres
expériences,
mais une école
de contentement
qui nous apprenons
aussi par l'exemple
et le modèle
des hommes fidèles.
Et donc nous avons
constaté
que cette école
nous présente
ce qui est
l'expression
la plus élevée
des joies.
L'expérience
la plus élevée
des joies
n'est pas
la maximisation
des plaisirs
qui nous poussons
réjouir dans cette vie.
Les plaisirs
sensoriels
des bonnes choses
que nous trouvons
dans les périodes
d'abondance.
La joie véritable
c'est la capacité
de traverser
des moments
où nous expérimentons
même de la tristesse
ou de la joie
sachant que nous sommes
en train d'expérimenter
une constance
d'assurance
supérieure aux circonstances.
C'est notre joie
dans le Seigneur
qui ne va jamais manquer.
Et donc là
la définition
de joie ici
du contentement
c'est
lorsque Paul dit
j'ai appris
à être content
de l'état
où je me trouve.
Elle est ou la vraie joie
c'est lorsque
nous traversons
n'importe quelle situation
de la vie
sans avoir
la tentation
de nous plaindre.
C'est de savoir
qui c'est
qui Dieu a déterminé
pour moi
aujourd'hui
elle est mieux
pour moi
aujourd'hui
à long terme.
et c'est un défi
pour nous tous.
Et donc
d'être content
de l'état
où je me trouve.
Ça ne veut pas dire
que Paul n'est pas
en train d'expérimenter
de la détresse.
Vous avez bien fait
de participer
à ma détresse
mais il sait
que même
cette période
de détresse
elle participe
à une expression
supérieure
de l'amour
de Dieu pour lui.
Il a toute l'assurance
qu'il est mieux
il l'a déjà.
Et donc ensuite
les contentements
et cette satisfaction
de l'état
où nous nous trouvons.
Les contentements
sont quelque chose
qui nous devons
apprendre
dans une école.
Ce n'est pas quelque chose
qu'on puisse apprendre
dans une université
ou par la théorie
des prédications
tout simplement.
Ce que vous devez saisir
peut-être ici
si vous étiez exposé
à l'hérésie
de la théologie
de la prospérité
c'est
la Bible
en sait clairement
qu'au lieu
de me battre
contre mon état actuel
même si je peux
utiliser des ressources
légitimes
pour chercher
à changer
les circonstances
je dois savoir
si j'ai prié
si j'ai fait
ce que je devais faire
je dois être content
je dois être
en paix
et accepter
que par cette voie
Dieu va
développer ma foi
développer mon intimité
avec lui.
Il est en train
de forger en moi
les caractères du Christ.
il est en train
de me permettre
de constater
attention
que j'ai beaucoup
plus d'endurance
que j'imaginais
dans chaque étape
de la vie
le nombre d'enfants
va grandir
les défis financiers
vont grandir
aussi
les demandes
vont grandir
aussi
et devant
chaque nouvelle étape
des défis
on croit
ne pas avoir
la capacité
d'être à la hauteur
on expérimente
parfois
des situations
de confort
et on regarde
des personnes
qui vivent
dans une structure
plus aisée
plus ordonnée
ou dans une culture
où les principes
publics sont plus
respectés
et plus nourris
et on arrive
à la conclusion
par exemple
que la meilleure
manière d'éduquer
nos enfants
c'est par
les homeschooling
par l'école
à la maison
et on va chercher
légitimement
à vivre
cette ordre
cette structure
etc
et nous ne pouvons pas
oublier
que lorsqu'Israël
n'a pas pu vivre
tous les meilleurs
principes
d'éducation
de leurs enfants
comme quand ils étaient
par exemple
dans l'esclavage
à l'Egypte
ou lorsque Daniel
a été en Babylone
ou la vie
dans son parcours
des vies de Joseph
ou même
l'éducation
des Moïse
comment Dieu
peut utiliser
ces circonstances
des batailles
constantes
pour forger
davantage
les pères
qui doivent faire
face à ça
en faisant
encore plus
d'efforts
pour protéger
l'éducation
de ces enfants
et tous
grandissent ensemble
les parents
sont plus solides
parfois
pour défendre la foi
les enfants
étant étirés
d'un côté à l'autre
dans la progression
de leur foi
ils ne sont pas
pris par surprise
lorsqu'ils arrivent
à l'université
et tous
sont forgés
ensemble
dans la fournesse
toutes ces pressions
là
il y a Calvin
qui a dit
une phrase
assez intéressante
à cet égard
pour Jean
il disait
les seigneurs
forment
ses meilleurs
soldats
dans les hautes
terres
de l'affliction
et voici
ce qu'il dit
Calvin
à cet égard
je travaille
en luttant
avec force
avec la force
des Christ
qui agit
puissamment
en moi
citant
Colossian
et ensuite
il dit
nous ne nous appartenons
pas à nous-mêmes
donc
que ni notre raison
ni notre volonté
ne règne donc
sur nos plans
et nos actions
nous appartenons
à Dieu
vivons donc
pour lui
et mourons
à plusieurs reprises
devant un nouveau défi
nous regardons
devant nous
j'aurais
tellement mieux
organisé ma vie
avoir du temps
pour faire
toutes les choses
et toutes les priorités
bibliques
de la manière
la plus paisible
et ordonnée
que possible
c'est légitime
on fera des efforts
pour les faire
et on doit aussi
accepter
que possiblement
dans l'idéal
de l'apôtre Paul
ça ne serait pas
une prison
qui jouerait
pour l'avancement
de l'église
et c'était
notamment
la prison
qui jouait
pour l'avancement
de l'église
car même
la maison
de César
se convertissait
à cause du fait
que Paul était
emprisonné
à Rome
c'est dans la mesure
de la force
que le Seigneur
pourvoit
et il faut
traverser
pour constater
il faut
traverser
pour constater
si nous ne sommes
pas résolus
et déterminés
à avancer
à embrasser
on peut être
privé
quelque part
de développer
l'effort
de constater
je ne savais pas
que j'aurais pu
faire
tout ça
dans la force
que le Seigneur
pourvoit
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que quand on voit
l'histoire de l'église
et même
plusieurs passages
d'écriture
c'est ce qu'on va retrouver
les contentements
dans les Seigneurs
et la constatation
qu'en traversant
les situations
difficiles
et les privations
extrêmes
les Seigneurs
sera toujours là
pour nous montrer
qu'il est
les biens suprêmes
qu'il ne manque jamais
c'est de dire
qu'on m'a dit
Polycarpe
à 86 ans
je les sers
il ne m'a rien manqué
il va couronner
donc son martyr
avec cette déclaration
et de l'autre côté
c'est de savoir aussi
que lorsque Dieu
pourvoit
a des besoins
pour nous restaurer
des bonnes conditions
de vie
ce qu'il est en train
de dire
c'est moi
la source
de ta restauration
moi j'ai du plaisir
à te faire
participer
aux bonnes choses
de cette vie
tu es dans un service
militaire fidèle
fatigant
et comme disait
Arsys Plot
je prends soin
de mon corps
et de mon repos
car mon corps
ne m'appartient pas
et il est consacré
à un service
fatigant
donc j'ai besoin
de me rendre
à Dieu renouvelé
afin de produire plus
et Dieu
il a la même
compréhension
et il peut faire
que l'apôtre Paul
traverse aussi
des moments
de satisfaction
sans s'accrocher
au bien
conscient
que plus tôt
ou plus tard
Dieu peut le demander
à nouveau
laisse tout ça
à côté
et continue
d'avancer
et donc
c'est un rappel
qui Christ
est notre bien
suprême
notre
sumum bono
et les fonds
omni bono
c'est à dire
la source
de tous
les biens
tout est réjoui
avec Christ
et particulièrement
dans l'avancement
de sa cause
et donc
l'école du contentement
fait usage
de toutes
les circonstances
et de tous
les contrastes
des circonstances
l'école du contentement
nous apprend toujours
à trouver
surtout les contentements
dans le Seigneur
j'ai pu tout
passer
lui qui me fortifie
dans des versets
les plus abusés
erronément
pour dire
que les personnes
peuvent désirer
n'importe quoi
dans cette vie
faire des dieux
les sponsors
de nos idoles
une vie charnelle
parfois
des désirs charnels
un attachement
à cette vie
parce que Paul
est ici en train
de dire
je peux traverser
même les pires
circonstances
car Christ
pourvoit toujours
les dynamos
la puissance
dont j'ai besoin
pour endurer
et pour faire avancer
et ici donc
nous voyons
ou nous considérons
la transition
vers quelque chose
de nouveau
aujourd'hui
le contentement
c'est
de trouver Christ
en tout
et partout
les bonnes choses
c'est Christ
qui me les donne
les difficultés
Christ sera toujours
là
la gouvernance
de ma vie
sa sagesse
me conduit
à développer
ma force
mon endurance
à entreprendre
pour la gloire
des dieux
pour les rois des dieux
donc nous voyons
une symétrie
incroyable
dans la provision
des dieux
car
par l'abondance
ou par la privation
il fait son royaume
avancer
il forme son caractère
en nous
et il promeut
notre joie
par là
la vraie joie
mais c'est intéressant
aussi
de voir aussi
une symétrie
encore plus grueuse
peut-être
car ça touche
à l'une des
des doctrines
les plus complexes
pour la compréhension
humaine
ça va même
au-delà
de la compréhension
humaine
et c'est 13
j'ai pu tout
par celui
qui me fortifie
et c'est 14
cependant
vous avez fait bien
de prendre part
à ma détresse
d'un côté
Paul
les ministres fidèles
complètement
convaincus
que la seule source
et la source
ultime
de tous ces soins
viennent directement
du Seigneur Jésus
vous êtes avec moi ?
je puis
tout
par celui
qui me fortifie
qu'est-ce qu'il est en train
de déclarer par là ?
je n'ai pas forcément
besoin d'attendre
la maturité
d'une église
pour partir
emplanter des églises
je ne peux pas
dépendre
des soutiens
des personnes
qui par des raisons
charnelles
ou par des raisons
des manques
des ressources
peuvent ne pas
vouloir contribuer
à l'avancement
de l'évangile
donc je pars
je prends les risques
je ne suis pas
si intéressé
même si par la grâce
des dieux
j'ai été sauvé
et conduit
envers un ministère
et supervisé
par une église
bien établie
bien ordonnée
bibliquement ordonnée
j'aurais pu avoir
l'impression
que par ces parcours
toute cette assurance
biblique
me serait assurée
et Dieu
de manière
complètement surprenante
peut nous quitter
d'un tel parcours
par des voies
qu'on n'arrive
même pas à imaginer
afin d'apprendre
l'école
de la dépendance
du Seigneur
et prendre
énormément
de risques
selon la vision
humaine
rendre la vie
vulnérable
sa vie
la vie
de la famille
vivre par la foi
dépendre du Christ
par la foi
la certitude
c'est
je peux
les faire
je vais
et en
les faisant
c'est inévitable
de constater
que Christ
ne va jamais
manquer
les risques
de suivre
une église
tellement située
à cet égard
c'est le risque
que Lloyd Jones
un jour
a dit
par rapport
à un candidat
à l'évangile
dans une église
tous ont dit
c'est un jeune
brillant
il a une capacité
de communication
incroyable
et tous étaient
prêts à valider
son appel
au ministère
mais
un homme
plus ancien
et plus expérimenté
après la parole
il a dit
la seule chose
je pense
qui manque
dans sa vie
c'est d'être
humilié par Dieu
il n'avait
jamais été
exposé
à des circonstances
de vie
où il devrait
apprendre
c'est la période
probatoire
dont la Bible
nous parle
à dépendre
exclusivement
du Seigneur
être fidèle
dans les peu
et donc
l'objectif
c'est
de créer
dans le cœur
de ses ministres
la nécessité
inhérente
au ministère
pastoral
de la prédisposition
à prendre
les risques
imaginez-vous
allez donc
partout
dans le monde
faites des disciples
de toutes les nations
sans GPS
sans ressources
sans internet
et j'essaierai avec vous
jusqu'à la fin du temps
toute autorité
m'a été donnée
vous allez faire face à la privation
la persécution
mais tout m'appartient
vous devez
être constamment prédisposé
à prendre des risques
à devenir des entrepreneurs
l'objectif
c'est pas
de créer
des petits empires
des petits royaumes
de faire la manutention
ou le maintien
de la roule
de rendre
les choses
qui sont
en train d'être faites
plus confortables
c'est un univers
qui est devant nous
et la commission
c'est l'évangélisation
de toutes les nations
et donc
ces hommes
doivent être
prédisposés
à prendre les risques
par contre
et c'est 14
et voilà la symétrie glorieuse
cependant
vous avez
bien fait
de prendre part
à ma détresse
et donc
pour que
ces ministres
avec toute son expérience
miraculeuse
avec Dieu
et c'est incroyable
par exemple
de s'asseoir
avec des hommes des dieux
très expérimentés
dans les champs missionnaires
qui ont beaucoup
dépendu de la provision
des dieux
de la délivrance
sous persécution
pour acheter
il a plein d'histoires
à raconter
de sa propre vie
aussi
du terrain missionnaire
des familles
qui prennent soin
mais les risques
et la tentation
quelque chose
qu'on ne voit jamais
dans la vie
d'apôtre Paul
c'est que cette personne
sente qu'elle a
une relation privilégiée
avec Dieu
ou qu'elle puisse
vivre dans une pleine
autonomie
qu'elle se sente
plus spirituelle
que les autres
et qu'au lieu
de prendre
toutes les peines
nécessaires
pour éduquer
une église
envers ses responsabilités
utilise
l'excuse
de la provision
de Christ
pour ne pas
traverser la peine
la vulnérabilité
de conduire
les églises
à la bonne maturité
donc lorsqu'il dit
vous avez bien fait
dans l'original
cette expression
bien
elle a à voir
avec droiture
avec justice
c'est d'être
sans réproche
c'est un signe
de maturité
et donc
cet homme
il doit apprendre
à faire comme
l'apôtre Paul
qui a été amené
au troisième ciel
et revenu
dans sa vision
à l'apôtre Paul
qui a été visité
par le Seigneur Jésus Christ
lui-même
dans la prison
l'apôtre Paul
qui va se soumettre
à rendre compte
à l'église
en tirage
à démontrer
quels étaient
les résultats
de leur investissement
lorsqu'il est parti
en mission
l'apôtre Paul
qui a su recevoir
les dons
des Philippiens
et donc
de la perspective
du ministre
je ne peux jamais
dépendre
d'une espèce
d'assurance
d'une stabilité
pour me lancer
et de l'autre côté
de la part
de l'église
la conscience
de sa responsabilité
à faire avancer
les remords de Dieu
par ses contributions
et ici nous sommes
devant la conciliation
l'harmonie
on n'a même pas besoin
de dire conciliation
comme dit
Arsisto
je n'ai jamais senti
les besoins
de réconcilier
des amis
mais la réalité
c'est qu'il y a
la souveraineté
du Seigneur Jésus
d'un côté
et la responsabilité
de l'église
de l'autre
la concurrence
et donc ici
nous voyons
cet autre aspect
glorieux
c'est la joie
que nous expérimentons
dans la maturité
missionnaire
d'une église
au verset 14
cependant
vous avez bien fait
donc c'est la joie
d'identifier
la maturité
d'une église
en bonne santé
ce que vous avez fait
c'est excellent
vous avez
pris part
à ma détresse
vous êtes avec moi
et c'est 14
donc le premier aspect
c'est
nous sommes devant
quelque chose
qui est décrit
comme expression
de maturité
de piété
excellence
la joie
de l'apôtre Paul
de contempler
les philippiens
de cette manière
la joie
des philippiens
d'entendre
de l'apôtre Paul
vous êtes une église mature
vous êtes en train
de faire quelque chose
d'excellent
excellent
ces indices
de maturité
qui portent la joie
sont aussi
des indices
particuliers
d'une maturité
précoce
donc remarquez
avec moi
d'abord
une expression
de compassion
envers un serviteur
fidèle
prendre part
à ma détresse
cette expression
attention
car
au commencement
de la prédication
de l'évangile
aucune église
n'entra
en compte
avec moi
remarquez bien
les mots
sont inspirés
toutes dans la parole
de Dieu
dans l'original
!
ça veut dire
koinoneo
c'est d'où vient
koinoni
qui on traduit
parfois
par
la communion
mais c'est un niveau
de communion
tellement intéressant
car c'est comme si
c'est comme si
l'église
des philippiens
était rentrée
dans la prison
avec l'apôtre Paul
ils se sentaient
plus du tout
abandonnés
ces ressources
étaient l'expression
de leurs sentiments
ces représentants
qui avaient dû
rendre
Epaphrodite
c'est bien
il était
la personnification
quelque part
de l'église
qui l'a envoyée
cette église
ensemble
s'est mise
dans la prison
avec l'apôtre Paul
pour renouveler
ses forces
la force
qu'il écrit
se pourvoit
à travers
l'amour
et les sentiments
d'une église
qui allait
dans la prison
comme le Seigneur Jésus
a dit
j'étais emprisonné
et vous êtes venus
mais visiter
c'est à moi-même
que vous avez visité
donc c'est
la compassion
la solidarité
la communion
dans les souffrances
l'apôtre Paul
au chapitre 3
disait
qu'il avait du plaisir
à prendre communion
avec les souffrances
du Christ
maintenant
l'église des Philippiens
est en train de prendre
la communion
avec les souffrances
du Christ
en étant en communion
avec l'apôtre Paul
ensuite
c'est une question
de justice
comme j'ai déjà dit
car aucune église
n'entraie en compte
avec moi
pour ce qu'elle donnait
et recevait
ça réjoint
l'enseignement
du Seigneur Jésus
parce qu'il dit
vous n'allez pas
porter avec vous
de l'argent
des sacs
de tuniques
ou des supports
extra
qu'est-ce qu'il dit
ensuite
car là c'est très mal
compris aussi
car
l'ouvrier
mérite son salaire
on utilise
ces textes
pour défendre
la missiologie
de la misère
c'est-à-dire
les missionnaires
ne peuvent rien voir
il faut toujours
dépendre
mais ce n'était pas
la logique du texte
du Christ
il était en train de dire
vous n'allez pas
dépendre de vos propres
ressources
vous n'allez pas
essayer de travailler
encore plus
pour faire une épargne
encore plus grande
pour pouvoir
et sponsoriser
vos propres
missions
c'est aller
acheter tout
partez
moi je m'assure
et toutes les personnes
qui recevront
l'évangile
véritablement
vont répondre
à l'évangile
qu'ils ont reçu
c'est qu'ils ont reçu
ils vont récompenser
avec les salaires
qui est digne
et honorable
et qui mérite
un pasteur
donc c'est un peu
il est en train
d'utiliser
un terme
qu'on est donné
à nouveau
qui n'est pas
tout simplement
un terme
de communion
d'affection
et de solidarité
mais c'est un terme
aussi
qui parle
des questions légales
des contrats
des business
c'est
de rentrer
en association
c'est de
se joindre à moi
devenir
participant
aucune église
n'est rentrée
en association
avec moi
pour ce qui concerne
à donner
et recevoir
vous comprenez
si nous avons
aimé parmi vous
les choses spirituelles
est-ce que c'est
une grande chose
de recevoir
de vous
les biens matériels
vous vous rappelez
que ce
l'ordre
de saint jésus
que ce
qui sert à l'évangile
qui vit de l'évangile
une question
de justice
et c'est un signe
de maturité
un autre aspect
c'est une maturité
d'assumer
la responsabilité
de devenir
un repère
précoce
l'église
des philippiens
la première
implantée par l'apôtre Paul
et l'apôtre Paul
est en train de dire
ici au verset 15
vous le savez
vous-même
philippiens
au commencement
de la prédication
de l'évangile
lorsque j'ai parti
de la macédoine
aucune église
n'entra en compte
avec moi
aucune église
n'était en train
de traiter
justement
ce qu'ils ont reçu
c'était le commencement
de l'évangile
particulièrement
dans la région
de l'Europe
en macédonie
et aucune église
n'est rentrée
en association
avec moi
et souvent
malheureusement
même lorsqu'il y a
une communauté
où les chrétiens
car vous connaissez
aussi d'autres
pasteurs
d'autres missionnaires
mais souvent
même si parfois
on constate
qu'on est devant
un homme fidèle
on hésite
à contribuer
à la mission
car on n'est pas
encore en train
de voir
les fruits
par contre
ici nous sommes
devant
une église
qui devient
un repère
précoce
de la maturité
car c'était
le commencement
de la prédication
de l'évangile
ils avaient
reçu
les suffisants
de la part
de Paul
pour savoir
qu'il devrait
honorer
et qu'il devait
contribuer
pour que
l'erreur
m'avance
mais ils n'étaient
pas en attente
ça c'était
vraiment bouleversant
dans mon expérience
missionnaire
car dès qu'on a été
connecté
à Pourachère
notre vision
de mission
a changé
complètement
car il nous a dit
pour moi
le plus important
c'est d'évaluer
l'authenticité
de ton appel
et comment tu traites
ta famille
et comment tu travailles
les résultats
c'est pas à vous
de produire
sinon vous serez
tenté
à montrer
des choses
qui ne sont pas
correspondantes
à la vérité
digne à les travailleurs
pas des résultats
de son salaire
justement
confronter
les services prêtés
à ce qu'ils méritent
mais avant ça
parce qu'on
on voyait
comment les missionnaires
sont traités
surtout devant
les petits
commencements
c'est dur
de trouver
des personnes
qui soient
prédisposées
à sponsoriser
un ministère
à investir
dans un ministère
depuis
leur petit
commencement
par contre
cette église
n'était pas
à l'attente
d'apprendre
avec d'autres églises
elles n'étaient pas
dépendantes
de la maturité
de l'exemple
des autres églises
ils sont dit
à nous
la responsabilité
de devenir
un repère
dès aujourd'hui
pour toutes les églises
de Macédoine
à nous de devenir
un repère
dans ces contextes
là même
où les Corinthiens
n'avaient pas
ni la maturité
possiblement
pas encore
renouvelé
dans leur conviction
pour pourvoir
au besoin
de l'apôtre Paul
c'est les ressources
des Philippiens
qui arrivent
et qui libèrent
l'apôtre Paul
pour continuer
de prêcher
parce que Paul
fait des tentes
ce n'est pas
les modes d'opération
réguliers
normal
c'était quelque chose
qu'il a ajouté
au travail
de l'évangile
car à partir
du moment
où les ressources
des Philippiens
arrivent à Paul
il se consacre
à nouveau
intégralement
au ministère
et donc ici
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
cette église
elle a dit
peu importe
si ma génération
si ma culture
si mon contexte
ne traite pas
les ministres
de Dieu
comme il faut
nous allons
traiter les ministres
de Dieu
comme il faut
nous serons
les repères
nous ne serons pas
à l'attente
de restaurer
la culture
de toutes les églises
nous allons pas
nous conformer
tout simplement
à la pratique
majoritaire
nous allons faire
ce qui est juste
ce qui est correct
ce qui nous trouvons
dans les écritures
aucune église
à part les Philippiens
n'est venue
à l'aide
la pôtre Paul
c'était donc aussi
la maturité
d'honorer
ces petits commencements
avec
de la régularité
donc c'est intéressant
non seulement
au petit commencement
verset 16
il dit
donc
dans l'état
présent des choses
ils viennent de faire
donc
qui est arrivé
à l'apôtre Paul
mais Paul est en train
d'évoquer
un passé
constante
des provisions
et des désirs
des pouvoirs
lorsqu'ils étaient
empêchés même
de les faire
donc là
il va dire
les séquences
vous les savez
vous même
Philippiens
au commencement
de la prédication
de l'évangile
aucune église
n'est entré en compte
avec moi
dans ce qu'il a donné
verset 16
il dit
car vous
m'envoyez
déjà à Thessalonique
et à deux reprises
des quoi pourvoir
à mes besoins
donc si on relise
les livres d'actes
on va voir
comment Paul
en plus
des privations financières
il était
soumis
à plusieurs
persécutions
emprisonnements
et les cœurs
des Philippiens
étaient
l'expression
des sentiments
du Christ
envers Paul
contre toutes
circonstances
difficultés
il y avait
une église
qui malgré
tout ça
toutes ces menaces
insistait
à s'approcher
de l'apôtre Paul
au milieu
de la mission
pour dire
voici
l'expression
de nos sentiments
les seigneurs
avec toi
et remarquez bien
comment cette église
a pu donner
l'espoir
au cœur
de l'apôtre Paul
et de la force
pour continuer
d'avancer
car même si
plusieurs semblaient
n'aient pas
avoir la reconnaissance
qui était juste
la préoccupation
qui était nécessaire
il y avait
cette église fidèle
qui venait
de naître
mais qui était
déjà très mature
par la grâce
des dieux
une vocation
particulière
et généreuse
des Philippiens
donc la régularité
était aussi
un signe
d'immaturité
précoce
pour cette église
c'était aussi
la maturité
et c'est possiblement
ce qu'ils ont vu
ou ce qu'ils ont compris
des plus matures
compris des plus matures
dans ce qu'ils faisaient
la maturité
de savoir
qu'ils étaient
en train de participer
de manière concrète
à la promotion
du règne des dieux
à travers la vie
de l'apôtre Paul
donc remarquez bien
ce que l'apôtre Paul
va dire
au commencement
de la prédication
de l'évangile
regardez
combien déterminant
toutes les lettres
de l'apôtre Paul
sont quelque part
comme des prédications
registrées
ok
imaginez
si Dieu
n'avait pas
utilisé
les Philippiens
les dons
des Philippiens
dès le commencement
!
dès la prédication
de l'évangile
qu'est-ce qui nous resterait
en termes de Bible
par exemple?
vous comprenez?
et donc ici
nous voulons
être très clairs
au verset 17
ce n'est pas
que j'achèche les dons
j'ai appris
à être content
dans toutes circonstances
si vous ne pourriez pas
Dieu va pourvoir
ne vous inquiétez pas
mais
je ne suis pas préoccupé
des dons
que je puisse recevoir
mais je cherche
attention
les fruits
qui abondent
pour votre compte
quelle était
l'une des motivations
principales
pour l'apôtre Paul
les fruits
qui abondaient
pour son propre compte
tout par la grâce
de Dieu
nous sommes ensemble
tout par la grâce
de Dieu
toutefois
moi
Paul il dit
j'ai travaillé plus que tous
toutefois pas moi
mais la grâce de Dieu
qui travaille à moi
1ère 21
ok
par contre
il sert à reconnaître
aussi
l'apôtre Paul
qui est tout comme
toute profession
et particulièrement
les professions
des 1ères
quantitaires
neufs
par exemple
sémés
cultivés
raccoltés
ou les bœufs
ou les régiments
militaires
une bataille
qui ne cesse pas
si on n'est pas
constamment
en train de chercher
à faire avancer
les royaumes
l'avancement
sera proportionnel
à l'emploi
du service
vous êtes avec moi
les fruits
qu'on va raconter
sera proportionnel
donc de manière
exceptionnelle parfois
comme dans un ministère
de Jérémie ou Esaïe
la culture
est tellement corrompue
qu'on ne verra pas
beaucoup de fruits
on ne verra pas
des fruits proportionnels
à la manière
dont on travaille
c'est possible
qu'on voit
ce type d'exception
mais comme
tous les types
d'activités
une église
prospérera
les royaumes
des dieux
avancera
à la mesure
à la proportion
où ses ministres
se consécaront
à temps plan
pour les ministères
sauf qu'ils ne peuvent pas
sortir de leur
occupation séculière
s'ils ne trouvent pas
des églises
qui sont les moyens
ordinaires
des dieux
établis pour dieux
et s'est disposé
à les faire
ce qui fait
qu'on reconnaisse
dans un certain sens
que pour plus
que les ministères
pastorales soient
la vocation
la plus pertinente
nécessaire
et digne
pour un monde
échoué
toutes les professions
sont saintes
car lorsque
en travaillant
séculièrement
les chrétiens
ont des ressources
qui puissent
sponsoriser
les ministres
à temps plan
l'église
a avancé
de cette manière
donc Christ
aurait pu
pouvoir directement
à l'apôtre
pour eux
mais Christ
a établi
que c'est la responsabilité
de l'église
de pouvoir
à ses ministres
et lorsque
les membres
de l'église
travaillent
et reçoivent
la rémunération
c'est biblique
qu'elles prennent
une portion
les prémices
et qu'elles
réconsacrent
à Dieu
particulièrement
à travers
les ministères
de leur église
locale
et si nous entendons
parfois
les croyants
très malades
spirituellement
qui disent
qu'ils n'aiment
pas trop donner
c'est une question
de justice
de reconnaître
que l'évangile
ne serait jamais
arrivé à lui
si ce n'était pas
par la contribution
des membres fidèles
des églises
au long de toutes
les années
de l'histoire
de l'église
nous sommes devant
la première
évangélisation
de l'Europe
toute la christianisation
qu'on a vue
par la suite
de l'histoire
de l'humanité
ça commence ici
et ça commence
avec une église
qui n'était pas
très aisée
mais qui a appris
qu'elle devrait
être généreuse
pour faire
le royaume des dieux
avancer
dès le départ
et donc
la maturité
de savoir participer
de manière concrète
à la promotion
de Rome
c'est-à-dire Paul
dans l'avant-garde
dans les premières lignes
de cette bataille
il savait
qu'il était en train
de tout donner
de se consacrer
et qu'il était en train
d'augmenter les crédits
des récompenses
des dieux
envers sa vie
les couronnes
qu'il va recevoir
à la gloire
c'est la grâce
des dieux
honorant
la grâce des dieux
qui appelait Paul
au ministère
mais ici
il est en train
de dire
vous qui contribuez
bien sûr
par la prière aussi
mais avec plus
que la prière
vous êtes en train
d'augmenter
les fruits
qui sera crédité
à votre compte
car vous êtes
en koinonie
avec moi
vous êtes associé
vous êtes mon partenaire
pour faire avancer
l'évangile
donc les fruits
de l'apôtre Paul
étaient les fruits
des Philippians
nous voyons ici
la maturité
d'une église généreuse
verset 18
j'ai tout reçu
et je suis
dans l'abondance
j'ai été comblé
des biens
en recevant
par Epaphrodite
ce qui vient
de vous
et donc ici
c'est intéressant
j'ai tout reçu
et donc
à nouveau
nous n'avons pas
les chiffres
mais il est traduit
comme abondance
comblé
des biens
ok
à chaque fois
que la Bible évoque
la manière
d'honorer
en nom des dieux
les principes
de la générosité
est récourant
donc la maturité
dès le départ
des Philippians
elle n'était pas
en train de calculer
d'étudier
les dépenses
de l'apôtre Paul
elle était en train
de considérer
que c'était
une opportunité
de l'honorer
d'exprimer
les sentiments
des dieux
et de même
envers les travails
qu'il faisait
et à nouveau
nous sommes devant
une nouvelle symétrie
glorieuse
dans la parole
des dieux
car ici
l'objectif
vers la générosité
est faire
que cet homme
qui se consacre
en vie difficile
vulnérable
soit motivé
au moins
par la réjouissance
temporaire
de ses biens
à continuer
d'avancer
par contre
de l'autre côté
on voit aussi
la maturité
de cette église
par la prestation
des comptes
car elle envoie
un homme
fidèle
et pas froidite
qui s'occupe
des rentrées
avec une lettre
très organique
on est d'accord
Philippiens
une lettre très organique
c'est l'amour
c'est la vie
qu'on voit ici
c'est la spiritualité
les principales
c'est la joie
chrétienne
mais c'était
une lettre aussi
qui était
une manière
officielle
la capacité
de l'église
c'est pour ça
que c'est très important
on n'a pas le temps
de rentrer dans les détails
mais c'est très important
de savoir identifier
les styles littéraires
ou la structure littéraire
de chacun
des auteurs bibliques
car c'était
unanime
par exemple
la reconnaissance
des textes publics
qu'on a
dès le départ
une lettre
d'épaule
avec toutes les caractéristiques
avec un niveau de connaissance
c'était qu'épaule
qui pouvait les faire
une lettre d'épaule
qui était
une espèce
aussi
de rendre
et pas fraudite
des nouveaux
à l'église
sans que personne
n'ait pu soupçonner
qu'il a pris une part
pour lui
que tous ces biens
dont Paul dit
je suis dans l'abondance
je suis comblé
des biens
c'est à dire
tous ceux
qui vous avez envoyés
à travers cet homme
m'est arrivé
comprenez
et Paul lui-même
comme je vous ai déjà dit
s'est soumetté
à l'église
d'Antioche
il y avait toujours
une espèce
de supervision
de transparence
pour attester
que l'homme des dieux
n'est pas quelqu'un
qui aime l'argent
et donc la maturité
qu'on trouve ici
c'est cette maturité glorieuse
et la prestation des comptes
et nous voyons donc
que cette autre source
des joies
qui est liée
à ces soins
qu'une église doit prendre
envers un ministre
c'est la source des joies
d'amener une église
à la maturité missionnaire
pour nous
ce que nous devons saisir
c'est par la grâce
de Dieu
et je suis convaincu
plutôt par manque
des besoins
par manque
des ressources
une église qui a commencé
dans une ville
très chère
par la grâce
de Dieu
a pu compter
avec la générosité
d'autres églises
et nous savons
que nous sommes
en train de traiter
il faut prier pour ça
c'est de l'intérêt
de l'agence missionnaire
qui sponsorise
les ministères pastorales
au sein de cette église
qui est le salaire pastorale
passe par l'église
par des mesures
de transparence
de rédivabilité
mais aussi
car
et surtout
c'est la responsabilité
de l'église locale
de prendre soin
de ses ministres
et c'est la responsabilité
que je rajoute
sur nous
en tant qu'église
de dans une culture
d'église
où l'office pastoral
a été détériorée
par la mauvaise pratique
d'un côté
par des abus financiers
et qui devant ces défis
plusieurs églises sont devenues lâches
par rapport à l'enseignement biblique
de quelque chose
qui est devenu tabu
à cause de l'amour
de l'argent général
dans nos sociétés
que nous ne soyons pas
rétrécis
en tant qu'église
devant les challenges
d'embrasser l'enseignement biblique
à cet égard
et selon l'exemple
de Philippian
devenir
en repère
pour notre génération
de traiter
les ministères pastorales
avec une telle dignité
que la génération
des enfants de pasteurs
et des enfants
de la communauté
puissent regarder
la vocation pastorale
comme une œuvre digne
qu'ils ne soient pas
découragés
de considérer
que si les médecins
ont la capacité
de prendre soin d'un corps
qui va bientôt mourir
ces hommes sont en train
d'être les médecins
des âmes
et donc dans une génération
qui a été
corrompue
à des raisons différentes
nous puissions faire
comme les Philippians
nous allons devenir
les repères
pour cette génération
et nous allons être généreux
envers nos ministres
et envers la promotion
de l'évangile
là où on trouvera
des ministres fidèles
pour envoyer
pour la vie
et nous allons
nous allons